eine frage des gewissens nach hoch
emotionaler debatte stimmt der bundestag
gegen eine radikale reform bei der
organspende geld gegen kohle bund und
länder einigen sich auf
ausgleichszahlungen in milliarden-höhe
sowie genaue restlaufzeiten endlich
regen immerhin eine atempause in
australien doch die buschbrände dürften
wieder aufflammen
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
petra gerster guten abend willkommen bei
heute am donnerstag mit sport stehen
norbert lehmann wenig später
präsentieren
einen schönen guten abend auch von mir
solch aufwühlende debatten sind selten
im bundestag denn das thema organspende
geht jeden an
jeder kann plötzlich auf ein fremdes
organ angewiesen sein
doch es sind einfach zu wenige die
bereit sind ihre organe zu spenden
dennoch stimmten die abgeordneten gegen
einen radikalen neustart
das wäre die sogenannte
widerspruchslösung von
gesundheitsminister spahn gewesen
danach wäre jeder potentiell organspende
der nicht aktiv widerspricht die
variante ist vom tisch es kommt die
sogenannte entscheidungslösung
organspende wird also nur wer sich
bewusst dafür ausspricht
bevor wir gleich von der
außergewöhnlichen und emotionalen
diskussion im parlament berichten
zunächst der blick zu einem betroffenen
verena mängel
eine spenderniere christian westrich
braucht sie dringend seit drei jahren
bestimmt die dialyse seinen alltag und
je länger er auf die spenderniere wartet
desto größer sind körperliche und
seelische belastung also ich hab gleich
staat bekommen dauert viertel 79 jahre
bis man was kommt was bekommt oder man
muss glück haben oder madalyn der
familie war es ja aber bei mister linde
familie so dass halt keiner mehr da ist
wohl mehr an organspenden kann
in deutschland wurden im vergangenen
jahr 2009 195 organe gespendet von 932
spendern
damit ermöglichte jeder spender mehr als
drei schwerkranken eine neue
lebenschance in deutschland dürfen
organe nach feststellung des hirntodes
weiterhin nur dann entnommen werden wenn
ein betroffener dem zu lebzeiten
zugestimmt hat stellvertretend dürfen
auch die angehörigen für die verstorbene
person entscheiden
transplantationsmediziner professor
urban seester sieht aber gerade das
kritisch das größte problem ist dass den
angehörigen von den verstorbenen
organspenden könnten dann schwierige
fragen gestellt werden müssen immer ganz
ungünstigen situation deutschland ist im
internationalen vergleich ein
schlusslicht bei der zahl der
organspender dialysepatient christian
westrich hätte sich die
widerspruchsregelung gewünscht für ihn
beschäftigen sich die menschen zu wenig
mit dem thema wenn sie krank werden
würden sie vielleicht anders entscheiden
ob sie das machen wir nur da nicht er
selbst war schon lange vor seiner
erkrankung organspender und meint jeder
soll seine organe spenden
in deutschland warten jeden tag rund
9000 menschen sehnsüchtig auf die
erlösende nachricht wir haben ein organ
für sie doch oft vergeblich deutschland
ist wie eben gehört bei der organspende
schlusslicht in europa das soll sich
ändern
darüber waren sich die abgeordneten im
bundestag einig über den weg dorthin
weniger cornelia schiemenz über eine
emotionale debatte ohne fraktionszwang
es sind bundestagsdebatten wie diese die
im gedächtnis bleiben absolut still ist
es als gitta connemann von ihre
mitarbeiter erzählt der starb weil ein
spenderorgan für ihn fehlte
wenn 33 jahre alt gerade vater geworden
nur einen monat nach der geburt seines
kindes wurde eine lebensgefährliche
erkrankung festgestellt
eine transplantation war die einzige
hoffnung aber der anruf kam nicht so oft
kommt der lebensrettende anrufe nicht im
ziel sind sich deshalb alle abgeordneten
einig leben retten mehr menschen zu
potenziellen organspendern machen
84 prozent der menschen wollen spenden
aber nur 40 haben einen ausweis diesen
84 prozent wollen wir ermöglichen ganz
einfach sich zu registrieren und das ist
ein großer unterschied ob ich im ausweis
wenn ich noch mein portemonnaie bahn
getragen weil kleidern
dabei habe oder und das ist unser
vorschlag ein online register zu
schaffen wo sich jeder eintragen kann
die große mehrheit schließt sich dieser
argumentation an eine spende muss eine
spende bleiben
die befürworter der widerspruchslösung
sind nicht weniger emotional die kleine
lilly die ich im krankenhaus besucht
habe und die so dringend auf ein
spenderherz warten sagte wenn man tut
ist braucht man doch so ein organe gar
nicht mehr ich muss ihnen sagen ich
finde sie hat recht
jens spahn ist mit seinem radikalen
ansatz gescheitert geht trotzdem
optimistisch aus der debatte
schon die debatte ist ein wert an sich
und dass wir so einen großen konsens im
deutschen bundestag auch im
gesellschaftlichen konsens pro
organspende haben
das ist nicht selbstverständlich am ende
glückwunsch an die initiatoren des
gegenentwurfs der mit breiter mehrheit
der abgeordneten angenommen wurde
fragt man übrigens die deutschen in
sachen organspende dann wäre es wohl die
widerspruchslösung geworden
im aktuellen zdf politbarometer fanden
61 prozent der befragten diesen
vorschlag am überzeugendsten
diese und andere aktuelle zahlen nachher
im heute-journal oder jetzt schon auf
heute.de wie immer natürlich auch zur
sonntagsfrage und zu der nach den
beliebtesten politikern in deutschland
es wurde der erwartete lange abend im
kanzleramt kurz nach
doch dann stand er der fahrplan für den
kohleausstieg in deutschland
ausgehandelt von bundesregierung
kohleländern und kraftwerksbetreibern
klar ist es wird ein sehr teurer
abschied von der kohle milliarden für
die betreiber milliarden für die
regionen und die beschäftigten
jürgen kehl mit den details der einigung
klar ist jetzt der strukturhilfe fonds
für die betroffenen regionen kommt um
fast 40 milliarden euro das ziel
zehntausende neue jobs für die
beschäftigten der kohleindustrie weitere
4,35 milliarden euro erhalten die
betreiber von kraftwerken die schon in
den 20er jahren ihre meiler abschalten
davon gehen 26 milliarden euro in den
westen 1,75 milliarden bekommen die
energieerzeuger im osten deutschlands
neue details gibt es für einzelne
standorte so wird das
braunkohlekraftwerk stopper und sachsen
anhalt nun doch bis 2034 laufen
trotz aller proteste datteln 4 das
umstrittene neue steinkohlekraftwerk in
nrw geht ans netz und der hambacher
forst bleibt erhalten das heißt keine
weitere abholzung für den tagebau der
fahrplan steht spätestens bis 2038
solcher kohle ausstieg geschafft sein
ende der 20er jahre wird geprüft ob das
aus für die kohle auch schon 2035
möglich ist kaum sind die eckpunkte der
einigung bekannt hagelt es kritik aus
der opposition und von umweltverbänden
der weg zum ausstieg aus der kohle sei
ein irrweg unnötig teuer dazu
die fdp fürchtet um die sicherheit der
energieversorgung die beteiligten
politiker dagegen sprechen von einem
großen erfolg
einen pakt der vernunft weniger mit den
reaktionen im stehen die langen
verhandlungs nichte ins gesicht
geschrieben neben müdigkeit sitzen hier
auch zufriedenheit und eigenlob
nebeneinander
das was wir hier haben ist ein gutes
eine gute einigung für den klimaschutz
weil deutlich wird dass wir es ernst
meinen
wir sind das erste land was verbindlich
aus atom und kohle aus steigt am ende
ging es in der vergangenen nacht vor
allem um die frage wer zuerst aussteigt
das ergebnis nordrhein westfalen beginnt
die drei ausländer folgen alle zufrieden
mit den zugesagten strukturhilfen 40
milliarden in den nächsten 20 jahren für
die betroffenen regionen
damit sollen neue arbeitsplätze
entstehen
es ist genau eine liste definiert was
denn da entstehen soll das umstrittene
steinkohlekraftwerk datteln vielen nrw
wird nun doch ans netz gehen die ost
ministerpräsidenten hatten gefürchtet
dafür opfer bringen zu müssen das müssen
sie nun nicht hinter der entscheidung
stehen sie aber auch nicht dort zu
müssen finanziell vielleicht
nachvollziehbaren gründen im netz das
haben aber wie gesagt die zu
verantworten die dann auch letztendlich
auf bundes und landesebene wird oder
sagen auch umweltschützer sind bei
dieser entscheidung empört der
klimaschutz komme insgesamt zu kurz drei
viertel aller kraftwerkskapazitäten
sollen erst ab silvester 29 abgeschaltet
werden das ist klimapolitisch
unverantwortlich und auch
energiepolitischer irrsinn weil das die
netze verstopft und damit am ende auch
den zügigen ausbau der erneuerbaren auf
abbremst frieden soll hier im hambacher
forst einziehen in garzweiler wird der
tagebau noch weitergehen proteste
dagegen wurden heute schon angekündigt
von der geplanten grundrente sollen mehr
menschen mit kleinst renten profitieren
als ursprünglich geplant nach dem
entwurf des arbeitsministeriums würden
rentner ab 33 beitragsjahren aus
erwerbsarbeit kindererziehung oder
pflege einen zuschlag bekommen das wären
zwei beitragsjahre weniger als bisher
gedacht und 1,4 millionen menschen
würden mehr geld erhalten zu 70 prozent
frauen
die fdp im untersuchungsausschuss
fordert das smartphone von
verkehrsminister scheuer sicherzustellen
um zu verhindern dass möglicherweise
wichtige daten zur aufklärung der maut
affäre eventuell gelöscht werden scheuer
hatte verträge mit zwei mautbetreiber
führenden geschlossen bevor der ogh
darüber urteilte dieser erklärte die pkw
maut für rechtswidrig
libyen ist ein gespaltenes land seit
jahren herrscht bürgerkrieg
heute nun reiste außenminister maß
überraschend dorthin und traf den
ehemaligen general haffter um ihn für
den internationalen gipfel am sonntag in
berlin zu gewinnen
es geht um eine friedliche zukunft für
libyen
maas sagte nach dem gespräch haffter
habe sich bereit erklärt den
waffenstillstand einzuhalten
er kontrolliert weite teile des landes
und wird zum beispiel von saudi arabien
und russland unterstützt sein
gegenspieler ist der von der uno
anerkannten ministerpräsident auf dessen
seite unter anderem katar und die türkei
wer in deutschland ein öffentliches amt
innehat lebt immer gefährlicher
durchschnittlich viermal am tag gibt es
politisch motivierte straftaten gegen
amts und mandatsträger gestern erste
schüsse auf das bürgerbüro des
spd-bundestagsabgeordneten karamba diaby
in halle in sachsen anhalt im bundestag
heute für ihn viel solidarität und
rückendeckung
david gebhard aus berlin er habe
solidarität von tausenden menschen
erfahren
auch die bundeskanzlerin verspricht
heute unterstützung karamba diaby
abgeordnete der spd geboren im senegal
in der scheibe seines bürgerbüros in
halle waren einschusslöcher entdeckt
worden
also ich bin fassungslos und finde dass
gewalt ist keine mittel einfach um seine
ziele zu erreichen ich kämpfe dafür dass
wir zusammenhalten und da lasse ich mich
nicht einschüchtern von einer minderheit
der andere meinung
die zahl politischer straftaten gegen
amts und mandatsträger insgesamt
alarmierend 1241 zählte das bka im
vergangenen jahr bis anfang dezember
die meisten angriffe wurden laut
innenministerium durch rechtsextreme
verübt mutmaßlich auch der mord am
kasseler regierungspräsidenten walter
lübke
wir müssen als staat hier auch zähne
zeigen und ich finde jeder der für die
menschen sich einsetzt für das
gemeinwesen einsatz hat verdient dass er
den schutz der gemeinschaft genießen
auch in einer aktuellen stunde des
bundestags geht es heute um gewalt gegen
repräsentanten des staates
dies ist nicht die erste angriff auf
abgeordnete oder abgeordnetenbüros dass
dabei schusswaffen eingesetzt werden ist
eine neue qualität in der ablehnung von
gewalt sind sich redner aller fraktionen
einig nicht aber in der frage wer dafür
verantwortlich ist sieht auf dem linken
auge blind
dabei ist es gerade ins extremisten die
parlament unsere polizei anhalten
rechtsextreme strategien und kampagnen
mit ihren resonanzboden im internet und
auch in den parlamenten wollen diese
fahren sie wollen diese gewalt aus
worten sollen taten werden im fall diaby
sind die hintergründe noch offen der
staatsschutz ermittelt wie mittlerweile
so oft der rücktritt der russischen
regierung gestern war ein paukenschlag
jetzt drückt präsident putin aufs tempo
am morgen tag der zum ersten mal die
kommission die eine neue verfassung
erarbeiten soll wohl mit einer neuen
schlüsselposition für putin nach ablauf
seiner amtszeit und das parlament hat
den neuen ministerpräsidenten gewählt
den wirtschaftsexperten michael misch
schuss team ohne gegenstimme er
versprach den bürgern echte
veränderungen zum besseren regen in
australien selten war das eine so gute
nachricht wie jetzt rund fünf monate
nachdem dort die schweren brände
ausbrachen 28 menschen sind seitdem ums
leben gekommen mehr als 2000 häuser
zerstört worden und niedergebrannt ist
eine fläche größer als portugal der
regen jetzt immerhin eine atempause für
alle betroffenen
von entwarnung will aber noch niemand
sprechen normen odenthal
gütiger gott segne uns mit regen steht
da gebete und wünsche sind wahr geworden
an diesem tag regen fällt auf
verbranntes land die blue mountains eine
gute autostunde von sydney entfernt
haben schwer gelitten in den vergangenen
wochen es regt nun endlich nur für viele
regionen kommt das viel zu spät und wie
viel ist das jetzt was kommt wirklich
runter das wird darüber entscheiden wie
groß die verschnaufpause wirklich ist
eine verschnaufpause wieso nötig wäre
noch mehr als 100 feuer lodern allein in
diesem bundesstaat im krisenzentrum von
new south wales laufen alle fäden
zusammen 24 stunden tag für tag seit
wochen seit monaten seit die brände
ausbrachen und kein ende nehmen wollen
im kampf gegen das feuer müssen die
kräfte gut eingeteilt werden darum geht
es hier
der regen wird nicht ausreichen um die
feuer zu löschen wir machen uns da keine
illusion
es wird wieder abtrocknen die brände
werden sich wieder ausbreiten aber für
den moment können unsere leute
vielleicht wirklich mal kurz durch das
wasser das der himmel schickt bringt
erleichterung keine frage aber es bringt
tatsächlich auch neue sorgen asche wird
in die flüsse gespült raubt sauerstoff
lässt fische verenden auch in
trinkwasserreservoirs landen die brand
rückstände in malaga staudamm bei sidney
haben sie schon große schmutz sperren
ausgelegt es ist ein neues kapitel in
der australischen misere und nun zum
sport norbert und zum biathlon-weltcup
in europa denkt ja unterließ für die
deutschen männer heute besser als
gestern für die frauen
denn benedikt doll hat den sprung aufs
podest geschafft der ex weltmeister
wurde dritter im 10 kilometer sprint und
musste sich nur zwei franzosen
geschlagen geben
[Musik]
der 29 jährige freut sich über seinen
zweiten podestplatz in diesem
weltcup-winter die basis für den dritten
platz heute 10
ihre treffer vor heimischer kulisse es
macht richtig spaß hier zu laufen und ja
schön mit so einer laut starken stimme
angefeuert zu werden
der mann in gelb matta fourcade aus
frankreich bleibt ebenfalls fehlerfrei
feiert hier in ruhpolding seinen 76
weltcupsieg und baut seinen vorsprung in
der gesamtwertung weiterhin auf
lachender zweiter vor cards landsmann
kaka wie oje morgen abend start der
bundesliga-rückrunde schalke gegen
gladbach ein echtes spitzenspiel
gelsenkirchens trainer david wagner ganz
gelassen
morgen ist es uns auch relativ egal dass
dieses spiel gegen gladbach ist dass wir
die saison eröffnen auch wenn ich das
relativ cool finden ganz ehrlich zu sein
weil das spricht ja dann auch ein
bisschen dafür dass einiges richtig
gelaufen ist bei diesen zwei teams das
ganze morgen live zu sehen bei uns im
zdf 20.15 geht's los
ja und heute abend handball in wie in
deutschland gegen weissrussland im
ersten hauptrundenspiel geht es für das
schwächelnde team von trainer christian
prokop schon fast um alles oder nichts
denn ohne einen sieg rückt ein
halbfinaleinzug in weite ferne
die anspannung steigt bei den deutschen
handballern kurz vor dem anwurf in wien
das deutsche team will die
durchwachsenen vorrunde hinter sich
lassen
doch es wartet eine der
torgefährlichsten mannschaften des
turniers weißrussland ist eine tempo
mannschaft die ihn von dem tollen
trainer trainiert wird der ihnen
beigebracht hat taktisch sehr breit sehr
diszipliniert über alle positionen
druckvoll zu spielen auf einen sich zu
konzentrieren ist nicht angebracht bei
dieser mannschaft um am kreis eine
option mehr zu haben nominierte
christian prokop heute johannes dollar
für marian michalzik nach viel hängt
außerdem davon ab ob torhüter andreas
wolf endlich ins turnier findet mit
einem erfolg heute bliebe die chance
aufs halbfinale erhalten
das wasser bleibt spannend zum wetter
heute war noch so ein frühlingstag in
weiten teilen des landes aber das wird
sich zum wochenende hin ändern
zu den einzelheiten gleich gunther
tiersch das war es von uns schön dass
sie dabei waren
christian sievers erwartet sie um drei
viertel 10 zum heute journal
und wir sind morgen wieder an dieser
stelle punkt 19 uhr
schönen abend noch
[Musik]
und einige zuschauer hat das milde
wetter treibt ja schon die winterlinge
hier aus dem boden aber jetzt wird es
doch wieder etwas kälter werden morgen
haben wir allerdings noch mal einen
milden tag und der wird auch weitgehend
sonnig sein aber sonst nähern sich diese
wolken und legen sich über den westen da
fängt es an zu regnen und zum wochenende
kommt dann auch die kältere luft zu uns
heute nacht sternenklarer himmel ein
paar nebelfelder bilden sich vor allem
hier am main und an der donau und dann
wird es frostig in süddeutschland so von
sachsen thüringen bis zu den alpen 0 bis
-5 grad sonst bleibt es im norden und
westen frostfrei tagsüber ändern sich
die temperaturen kaum gegenüber heute
sieben bis elf oder auch 13 grad am
oberrhein während im östlichen bayern
vier bis sechs grad
es wird ein freundlicher vormittag mit
sonnenschein allerdings werden die
wolken im westen langsam schon dichter
und wir haben noch den nebel und
hochnebel am main und an der donau
nachmittags ist ja dann weg dann scheint
auch dort die sonne
dafür haben wir dann dichte wolken im
westen und es regnet von der nordsee bis
zum schwarzwald dazu frischt auch der
süd- bis südwestwind ein bisschen
stärker auf ja die aussichten es wird
kühler auf jeden fall wechselhafter und
vor allen dingen so sie durch der donau
an den alpen schneit zeitweise am
wochenende
ansonsten am montag wird es wieder
freundlicher ich wünsche euch noch einen
schönen abend und machen sie's gut